please go - they're all spooky I'm gonna  pick that one over on the street  forty years ago on Halloween night  Michael Myers murdered three people  after that horrific night he was sent  back to the institution in captivity  I have prayed every night that he would  escape Adele did you do that for so I  can kill him the bus crashed Michael  Myers escaped he returns I haven't  filled his home I need to protect my  family you have no security system Karen  you need help if it was real there's a  reason we're supposed to be afraid of  the sight I've been preparing for this  for a long time  it is not safe to be on the street  tonight he's here he is a killer but he  will be killed tonight  happy Halloween Michael  you  [Music]